Без важкої техніки, літаків у небі
і тисяч крокуючих військових на Хрещатику.
Ще місяць тому президент Володимир Зеленський заявив,
що військового параду до Дня незалежності не буде,
бо це дорого і помпезно.
На День незалежності військовий парад
помпезний і точно не дешевий.
А тепер замість параду влаштовують так звану Ходу гідності,
яка, судячи з усього, буде не менш помпезною і навряд чи дешевшою.
Постановкою свята займається відомий кліпмейкер Алан Бадоєв,
а серед запрошених - низка дорогих виконавців,
як-от Тіна Кароль, яка виконає гімн України.
У ході разом з президентом Зеленським візьмуть участь
представники цивільних професій, які зробили
значний внесок у становлення незалежності,
а також близько 400 військовослужбовців
та ветеранів війни на Донбасі, які, на думку
Офісу президента, особливо відзначилися на фронті.
Такий формат святкування Дня незалежності і
непрозорі принципи відбору учасників ходи обурює
нинішніх та колишніх військовослужбовців.
Я відчув плювок у бік тих хлопців, які воювали, в бік тих, хто загинув.
Мене це образило. Парад має бути.
Аби показати насамперед нашим громадянам, що ми є.
Це має стратегічне значення взагалі в зовнішній політиці.
Минулого року в нас були учасники з країн НАТО, пройшлися парадом.
Це велике досягнення.
Усі бачили фотографію, коли йдевійськовий парад,
і стоїть хлопець без однієї ноги на милицях.
Він весь парад отак простояв.
Я вважаю, що в першучергу паради потрібні для таких хлопців.
Допоки триває війна на Донбасі, військовий парад
на День незалежності має проводитися, хай і з меншим розмахом,
але не перетворюватися на розважальне шоу,
переконана ветеранська і волонтерська спільнота.
Тому військовослужбовці разом з ветеранами
вирішили провести свій парад - Марш захисників.
Він має відбутися після Ходи гідності.
Військовослужбовець ЗСУ, голова фронтових
парамедиків Ілля Лисенко переконаний,
що команда президента Зеленського мала
не розділяти цією темою суспільство,
а навпаки - об‘єднати, залучивши до розробки
концепції святкування Дня Незалежності громадянське суспільство.
Зеленський не мав права просто ухвалювати якесь рішення,
не узгодивши його, не провівши дискусії з усіма,
хто голосував і за нього, і був проти.
Також обіцяні Зеленським грошові премії військовослужбовцям
замість параду проблем військових не вирішать.
Одноразові виплати в тисячу-дві тисячі гривень
багато хто сприйняв як приниження.
У мене зарплата як у військовослужбовця 10 тисяч гривень.
А за квартиру я сплачую теж 10 тисяч гривень.
Насправді ця тисяча гривень премії нічого не вирішує.
Це навіть якось принизливо насправді...
З військовим парадом чи без - ідеться лише про один святковий день.
Решту днів у році військовим доводиться боротися
зовсім не з "помпезними" проблемами.
Держава має подбати про поліпшення забезпечення на фронті,
створення ефективної служби евакуації поранених,
про повноцінну реабілітацію та ресоціалізацію ветеранів,
допомогу з житлом та працевлаштуванням.
За освітою я поліграфіст. Усі роботодавці,
незалежно від форм власності, не дуже хочуть
колишнього "атовця", тим більше інваліда, бачити  своїм працівником.
А також - припинення корупції та бізнесу довкола війни на Донбасі.
Керівництву держави, країні треба боротися з корупцією.
Корупціонери стільки крадуть, що цей парад - це копійки у порівнянні.
На думку головного капелана Національної гвардії України отця Івана,
в ідеалі було об’єднати два марші в один,
а потім провести обговорення з громадськістю та військовими
і затвердити на законодавчому рівні, як та коли проводити паради.
У День незалежності священик піде на Марш захисників,
який завершиться спільним молебнем на Михайлівській площі.